i want to go back to the tweety tweets
and journey drinks here yeah i want to
ask you because i've been on the lives
of tick tock account before have you
ever have you ever been on the libs a
tick tock account like myself
well i mean you're tick-tocked you got
right right you know
why famous
yeah i
i
i don't i don't think i have or at least
to the extent that
i haven't ever been tagged or no one's
ever like
spotted me out
so i would have no idea i wouldn't be
surprised if i was on there making some
case for
why
hypocrites uh are with you know our
republicans or hypocrites or uh they you
know they they can't pick a lane or
whatever the topic might be so i
wouldn't be surprised if i was actually
on there i just don't know if i'm
actually there
uh i feel like the only ones that you
really know about is like when you get
like the defiant l's
uh post or something and then you get a
bunch of like yeah yeah yeah i've been
there too right i've had andy i've have
andy no trolls after me too
oh those those are great people yeah
well yeah and by great i mean terrible
people right the andy no nazis they're
fantastic you know they're more they're
not quite dark manga but they're kind of
close right andy nazis yeah well yeah
andy nazis uh thank you lisa um
she says minus ken for bonehead of the
church this is like an ongoing thing i
feel like i know i'd have to have a poll
just between the two of them i know
we'll see who wins between lisa and ken
thank you lisa for the
for the super chat um
taylor uh i i think is lorenz is that
zenda you say it yeah yeah he's a writer
for uh the washington post and this is
why it's trending apparently she wrote
an article that exposed the the woman
who's behind the libs of tic tac i i
actually tried to go this morning and
find that account i don't know that that
account exists anymore did he get banned
or something uh well i know in the last
week lifts of tick tock has gone through
a bunch of reporting
um
just i mean here's the thing
they do have posts that are just not
good
uh right they take content from tick
tock and post it on there in an attempt
to own someone now technically you're
using a video against someone's
uh
permission especially if it's used in
that wave so
um well but that's only if that's only
if it's not downloadable because if you
because you can set your tic tac i used
to set my tick tock account where you
couldn't download the videos right i
haven't done that anymore because people
they they still like screen grab them
and they rip them you know whatever so i
just like i just let him down uh yeah do
you want to go to the account the
account still exists i think it's being
yeah give me that give me the uh give me
the link if you've got it yeah um but um
um taylor here wrote the article she
said libs of tick tock has become a
powerful force online shaping right wing
media impacting anti-lgbtq legislation
and influencing millions by posting
viral videos aimed at inciting outrage
i wrote about the account the one behind
it and why it matters so you can go to
the washington post if you subscribe
actually i think washington post lets
you read like one or two articles a
month so if you're not at your one or
two article uh there also may or may not
be a plug-in for different browsers that
allow you oh okay
i'm not saying that you should use it
but if you were to google something
what would you what would you google
what would you google if you were
if you have a person was going to do
something right you might say like
bypass paywall
um
so bypass pay wall and then like enter
in the browser users oh okay like chrome
oh okay yeah so buy this paywall for
chrome right then there may be a github
uh url oh okay that you go to and i mean
we're saying you should use it yeah i'm
not saying you should use it i'm just
saying like
yeah i'm just saying you're not a
sponsored voice yeah you should
definitely not
do that yeah yeah okay yeah good um so
so taylor here has um what they're
calling doxing which is not doxing we
actually went through this with an
interview that we had with uh
that
is it is it that guy donish is that his
account i can i always forget uh
i think it's uh
that
guy guy that danish guy yep so donish um
he actually came on the show and talked
about doxing with us that was back in
december i believe um
yeah
and this is not doxing this is not
doxing by the way right no this is not
doxing right this is investigative
journalism it's not like there is here's
the thing the way that they got this
information they weren't hacking they
didn't go into anyone's private
information they got this information
from public areas online
the registrar through the not to be
confused public areas not to be confused
with your test testicles that you're
that you're right not yet well those are
privates but oh okay you did tucker
carlson they very much become publix
i just want to make sure yeah not to be
confused with publix the
uh market right the supermarket in in
florida and right the one with desantis
but right uh
the um
uh it's not doxing right oh holy [ __ ]
you gotta see this this is why i
couldn't find it you're blocked
[Laughter]
what happened to first amendment baby i
don't know i mean they're really pissed
off that they're you know being outed
and canceled or whatever but they
canceled me they blocked me
right why am i blocked that
you know what if you need to take a few
and go cried out you know with your beta
self yeah i'm sure that they would love
that that's probably what i i should go
tan my balls for a little while to gain
my to gain my man strength back so i'm
not so upset um
i actually i actually see this as a as a
badge of honor right like yeah no yeah
if you get i mean i've been blocked by
random people i've never encountered
with but because of something i may have
tweeted that did not tag them or via
association to someone else
uh i
am like oh who's this and then i click
it and then it goes you can't view it
because you're blocked and i'm like i've
never like uh
who's the guy that's always at cpac um
uh he's got like goatee not not not
miller um
oh you are you talking are you talking
about the um the the the guy who did get
her no no that's that's miller that's
the other killer oh uh
uh
uh oh oh sebastian gorka yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he has me blocked oh really on
twitter and i have literally never
tweeted
about him
that i know of well it's probably a list
it probably a list that he found no no
you just started blocking he's like all
these people are going to make fun of me
so i better block them
i would imagine that this block from
libs of tick tock i'd imagine it's
because
that they um posted a video of me
and then i probably like quote tweeted
it or something right like i wasn't yeah
like i went like oh my god i'm on
liberty a tick-tock oh no oh cause i'm
like i i don't give a [ __ ] about the
trolls like right i welcome the trolls i
don't want the girls now i don't want
them saying racist bigoted [ __ ] in the
comments like in our chat but i welcome
the trolls i want them to come and
listen to me i want them to figure out
you know what the hell i am about yeah
but so the the libs of tick tock uh
banning me isn't surprising because i
think i ended up there i don't know it
was probably three or four times that
people pointed out i actually didn't
follow the account and i don't think
they tagged the people um you know
someone has to see it and then
um you know
point it out to you right
but my my tick tock handle
is the same as my twitter handle at the
tony michaels so on the tick tock video
that they would rip because at the time
they would have to rip it
so they spent the time to record the
screen like the whole video yeah that's
how much they had to indoctrinate
themselves yes well that's the thing
that i loved and i think that's probably
what i said i don't know i have to go
back and search to find but that's
probably what i said i probably said i
don't allow people to download my tic
tac so you had to actually watch this
video yep to that not just to see what
it was about to just to download it
or to rip it just to post it on twitter
so i'm very satisfied
with what you did yeah i call it w yeah
it's a good one it's a good one i think
they did it several times and that's
probably why um that's probably why they
have me blocked i would imagine but to
answer the original question no none of
this is doxxing like i've worked with uh
i've worked on a few of
similar let's say not not similar in the
sense of like lips or tick tock stuff
but like for other people that have done
pretty egregious racist bigoted things
in public and they put themselves out
there and then obviously after the fact
they're like oh i got cancelled it's
like no
you did this to yourself
uh i've worked on a few different ones
help research i don't i will say this
i've worked in the background on a few
of these things i don't like to be the
center of attention to be like oh i've
identified this person that's not my
thing i don't need to bring in that type
of attention to
uh my account or like my kind of
personality brand whatever right uh but
i will help in terms of researching uh
and it's you know there are different
methods to do it i won't reveal what
those methods are obviously um but it
has nothing to do with hacking
look at you being all spyish and
secretive
the people that are afraid and get all
butt hurt about like getting their
information or getting themselves
discovered online
it is all things that they have posted
online right through various different
profiles they don't have to be the same
name or they use an email here that's
registered to this thing all publicly
accessible stuff
they put out there but it's also it's
also like through
like um you know if you find someone on
facebook and they don't really have a
lot of stuff posted but they have their
family members posted to their family
there's a ton of different things i can
have on there like oh i use the account
here but my account is actually
connected this other account and that
account has my email shown let's say
that you
had it on youtube and you're like oh
this this twitter account actually
connects this youtube account right and
i now see your face right and there's
ways of you know
looking for that there's also your
emails is attached to the account so you
can see what the email is so there's
ways that people
can uh
you know
reveal themselves in a in a in an uh
in a way that they aren't like really
sure right so it's not really doctoring
it no no you're not careless
you're mining the internet that which
anyone could do right again you're just
fine all the things that they put out
there right this is publicly accessible
again no one is hacking no one is is
accessing private information this is
all stuff that these boneheads
have put out there
and have revealed themselves they
thought it was they thought it was
nothing they thought it was hidden
whatever and then if you just
do a simple google search or on twitter
or youtube or something you'd be
surprised what you could find you know
depending on how also how unique your
name is or you know a
the profession you're in like you know
wouldn't be surprised oh i found uh i
found you on linkedin right you know
whatever and that's that's the other
thing too that i was just about to say
is like the linkedin thing when you go
on linkedin because like you're tying it
to your work like that's the whole point
of linkedin is like where you work and
then when you do that it like you know
you're just automatically saying hey
look at me i've got a job here's my job
and if i'm being racist in public right
it you know it really is dumb stuff i
want to go back to what uh right wing
cope says here about the elixir tick
tock thing real quick
um i think i think right wing code
points us out very well here libsa
tiktok is a proud defender of grown men
having sex with oh yeah i remember we're
still in middle school unsurprisingly
her entire narrative about teachers
grooming kids is massive projection yep
um this is about milo yiannopoulos i
don't know if people know this he kind
of he used to be
sort of suitable for the famous for he
was yeah he was a big
anti-lgbt guy or something with
breitbart um
he had his big personality he actually
he tried to write a book and then um
believe it or not bill maher had him on
his show and everyone was really [ __ ]
pissed off that bill maher had him on
the show and bill maher said this he
said sunlight is the best disinfectant
which i agree with i agree with and
after that interview after he went on
bill maher and bill maher basically
exposed him to a bright broader audience
people were like whoa this guy's really
[ __ ] gross this guy is despicable
he's vile and he lost his book deal and
he lost his position at breitbart i mean
it basically destroyed yeah i mean he
said some crazy stuff like there was a
he took a photo and i don't know if he
was like kind of goading people to
respond but he did have a photo where it
was like a syringe and also
uh
was it liquid vermectin or what was it
it was he he just did a new job he's a
[ __ ] i mean he's also got his like
conversion therapy club right well and
that's down in florida which is not
surprising in nazi florida
he's trying to start conversion therapy
centers but here here libs a tick tock
this woman who started this account said
milo yiannopoulos didn't say anything
wrong are people seriously arguing that
you're not ready for sex under 16
that was all a distraction the lgbt
propaganda agenda is much more of a
threat to the minds of children
so basically pedophiles
pedophiles aren't a threat it's it's the
lgbt community because
they prefer their same gender of the
person they love this is really [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] right this is again this is
again the same dark maga the the the
evil empire that wants to take over our
country they're sexualizing this woman
who has a lip is a tick tock is
sexualizing children's gender they're
sexualizing it they're sexualizing their
their preference of who they love like
look
just because you may or may not be gay
doesn't mean you can't fall in love with
someone else right this is all [ __ ]
nonsense and [ __ ] and this is the
[ __ ] that they used milo for because he
was openly gay i think he was actually
married wasn't he or was he just
had a
uh
a boyfriend yeah well i i i can't
remember if they were if they were
actually engaged or they were married or
getting married like there was a
narrative there right but i can't
remember well there's also the big thing
the big thing for him was that he was
married to uh a black guy and he was
using that as a music i'm not racist
right i'm not racist but i work for
breitbart and i write this pretty
defamatory stuff around like just like
just crazy insane stuff
uh
for
oh i just retweeted the wrong one i
really tweeted rick wilson your your
arch enemy oh boy uh oh we'll we'll read
rick's tweet since i retweeted it just
for you go ahead but yeah uh let's see
if i'm just quickly looking at
uh his wikipedia to see if there's
anything about that but yeah i remember
that because it was brought up during
his interview with
yeah with bill maher because it was kind
of like well i can't be anti-gay because
i am i'm just anti-gay it's like really
weird it was like you could be in a
group and you could still be self-hating
like the two rights it's kind of the
candace owens effect right right it's
kind of the same [ __ ] that christian
walker candace owns and and really it's
the maga effect because really manga is
against themselves like they're against
their own self-interest they're against
what they're actually saying like oh we
want better jobs like yeah but you're
voting in people who are doing away with
the good jobs uh rick wilson i'll read
this tweet here gabe's arch nemesis here
um old and busted faux
full rage over us laughing at tucker's
testicle tanning that's good tucker's
testicle tanning new hotness faux rage
over libs of tick tock being outed it
really is stupid